>>> YOU ARE LIVE ITHE CNN
"NEWSROOM," I'M JIM ACOSTA IN
WASHINGTON.
TER MORE THAN A YEAR OF DEBATE
AND DELAYS, A MAJOR PART OF THE
BIDEN AGENDA IS ON THE BRINK OF
BECOMING REALITY, RIGHT NOW THE
SENATORS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
PASSING THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT.
IT WAS GIVEN LIFE BY KYRSTEN
SINEMA THIS WEEK.
IF IT PASSES IT WILL BE THE
BIGGEST CLIMATE INVESTMENT IN
U.S. HISTORY AND MAKE MAJOR
CHANGES TO HEALTH POLICY.
JESSICA DEAN IS ON CAPITOL HILL
FOR US.
EARLIER IN THE WEEK THIS WAS
ABOUT GETTING KYRSTEN SINEMA ON
BOARD BUT NOW SENATOR BERNIE
SANDERS SAID THE BILL DOES NOT
GO FAR ENOUGH, WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
>> HE REPRESENTS THE FURTHER
LEFT OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
WRANGLING ALL 50 OF THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS HAS BEEN NO
SMALL FETE, GETTING SENATOR
MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA ON
BOARD.
ULTIMATELY WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL MOVE FORWARD, THE QUESTION
IS WHEN.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY LENGTHY,
COMPLEX, TEDIOUS PROCESS THEY'RE
USING, A SPECIFIC BUDGET PROCESS
THEY'RE USING TO GET IT THROUGH.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT WHAT'S IN
THE BILL, A LOT OF CLIMATE
PROVISIONS, ABOUT $369 BILLION
IN CLIMATE PROVISIONS, THE
BIGGEST INVESTMENT OUT OF THE
SENATE EVER.
HOPING TO REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS BY 40% BY 2030.
ALSO SOME TAX INCENTIVES IN
THERE TO PUSH RENEWABLES.
THERE'S ALSO SOME HEALTH CARE
COMPONENTS IN THEORY THAT WOULD
ALLOW MEDICARE TO NEGOTIATE THE
PRICE OF SOME DRUGS, ABOUT 10
DRUGS BY THE YEAR OF 2026 AND
EXTENDING BEYOND THAT, THE FIRST
TIME MEDICARE WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
DEMOCRATS WANTED IT TO BE BIGGER
BUT THIS WAS ABOUT WHAT THEY
COULD GET.
AND ALSO EXPANDING THE HEALTH
CARE SUBSIDIES FOR THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT FOR THREE
YEARS.
TO PAY FOR THIS, THERE ARE TAX
COMPONENTS AS WELL, INCLUDING A
15% MINIMUM CORPORATE TAX AND A
1.5% EXCISE TAX ON STOCK
BUYBACKS.
GETTING JOE MANCHIN ON BOARD
MEANT THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
IT WAS PAID FOR AND COULD BRING
DOWN THE DEFICIT.
TO THAT END WE ARE WAITING ON A
COUPLE OF THINGS TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD.
THE SENATE PARLIAMENTARYIAN
NEEDS TO RULE ON A FEW MORE
THINGS AND WE NEED TO GET THE
SCORES BACK FROM THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OFFICE.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO SCORE THIS,
SAY HOW MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST
AND WHAT IT'S GOING TO DO TO THE
DEFICIT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WAITING ON.
HERE'S SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER EARLIER TODAY.
>> WE HAVE THE BILL BEFORE US
THAT CAN WIN THE SUPPORT OF ALL
50 DEMOCRATS.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THE BILL WE
PRESENTED TO THE PARLIAMENTIAN
REMAINS LARGELY INTACT, THE BILL
WHEN PASSED WILL MEET ALL OF OUR
GOALS, FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE,
LOWER HEALTH CARE COSTS, CLOSING
TAX LOOPHOLES ABUSED BY THE
WEALTHY, AND REDUCING THE
DEFICIT.
>> SENATE REPUBLICANS ARE
UNIFIED AGAINST THIS.
ONCE THEY MOVE INTO VOTE-A-RAMA,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM HAD A
SPECIFIC WAY OF DESCRIBING WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO BE LIKE.
>> SO WHAT WIT VOTE-A-RAMA BE
LIKE?
IT'LL BE LIKE HEL.
THEY DESERVE THIS.
AS MUCH AS I REMINE JOE MANCHIN
AND KYRSTEN SINEMA FOR STANDING
UP AT TIMES, THEY'RE EMPOWERING
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MAKE THE
AVERAGE PERSON'S LIFE MORE
DIFFICULT.
>> Reporter: NOW WE SIT AND WAIT
FOR THEM TO MOVE FORWARD ON THE
MOTION TO PROCEED, THAT'S LIKELY
TO COME LATER THIS AFTERNOON,
EARLY EVENING BUT IT'S VERY
FLUID AT THIS POINT.
WE'LL KEEP YOU UPDATED.
>> AND WATCHING WITH BAITED
BREATH AT THE WHITE HOUSE TO SEE
IF IT GOES THROUGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> I'M JOINED BY DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR BEN CARDEN OF MARYLAND.
LET'S START WITH THE NAME, THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT YOU
HEARD LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYING THIS
IS NOT GOING TO HELP THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN OUT THERE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO
LINDSEY GRAHAM, IS THAT CORRECT?
>> FIRST, JIM, GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
IT WILL HELP THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN, BRINGING DOWN THE COST
OF HEALTH CARE, BRINGING DOWN
THE COST OF ENERGY IN THIS
COUNTRY, SAVING AMERICANS ON
THEIR FUEL BILLS AND ENERGY
COSTS.
IT WILL HELP DEAL WITH OUR
CLIMATE CHALLENGES.
AND IT BRINGS DOWN THE DEFICIT.
ALL OF THAT MEANS IT WILL HELP
US IN DEALING WITH THE COST
ISSUES THE AVERAGE AMERICANS ARE
FACING AND WILL BE POSITIVE IN
RESPONDING TO INFLATIONARY
PRESSURES.
>> AND WE JUST HEARD FROM THE
REPUBLICANS AND THEIR COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION,
AS YOU KNOW, SENATOR BERNIE
SANDERS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
SPECTRUM DOESN'T THINK IT GOES
FAR ENOUGH.
HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY ON THE
SENATE FLOOR.
>> WE HAVE LEGISLATION, WHICH
UNLIKE THE ORIGINAL BUILD BACK
BETTER PLAN, IGNORES THE NEEDS
OF THE WORKING FAMILY OF OUR
COUNTRIES IN CHILD CARE, PRE-K,
THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, HOME HEALTH
CARE, HIGHER EDUCATION AND MANY,
MANY OTHER DESPERATE NEEDS.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE'S GOING TO
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SENATOR'S CONCERNS
THAT HE JUST SPECIFIED THERE OR
IS THIS THE LAST BIG PIECE OF
THE BIDEN AGENDA THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT THROUGH CONGRESS BEFORE
THE MIDTERMS?
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT,
THIS BILL IS VERY, VERY KEY IN
MOVING FORWARD ON HEALTH CARE
COSTS, ENERGY COSTS, CLIMATE
CHALLENGES, DEALING WITH
INFLATION.
IT'S A MAJOR STEP FORWARD.
BUT IS IT THE END OF WHAT WE
NEED TO DO?
NO.
THERE'S OTHER ISSUES WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THE COST OF
CHILD CARE, THESE ARE OTHER
ISSUES.
BUT IN THIS BILL THERE ARE SO
MANY IMPORTANT THINGS WE'RE
GETTING DONE AND IT IS A MAJOR
STEP FORWARD.
BUT CERTAINLY IT'S NOT THE END
OF OUR ATTENTION TO HELP
FAMILIES DEAL WITH THE COST OF
THAT THEY'RE SUFFERING TODAY.
>> AND SENATOR, AS YOU KNOW,
THERE WERE SOME CONCESSIONS MADE
AS PART OF THIS DEAL TO SECURE
THE BACKING OF SENATORS KYRSTEN
SINEMA AND JOE MANCHIN, ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE WITH I GUESS THE
EXISTING POLITICAL REALITY HERE
IN WASHINGTON THAT THE BIDEN
AGENDA SEEMS TO HINGE ON THESE
TWO SENATORS?
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A 50/50 SENATE,
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE WHEN
YOU'RE MOVING ON A BILL LIKE
THIS YOU HAVE ALL 50 SENATORS
TOGETHER.
THAT'S NOT EASY, BUT WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS CASE.
SUCCESSFUL IN REGARDS TO THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL WE HAVE
MOVING FORWARD WITH CLIMATE AND
HEALTH CARE, ET CETERA.
BUT ALSO THE WAY WE PAY FOR IT.
IT'S A WAY THAT WILL NOT AFFECT
THOSE WHO HAVE INCOME UNDER
400,000.
IT WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES SO THAT
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE NOT PAYING
ANY TAXES WILL HAVE TO PAY SOME
TAXES.
IT DEALS WITH COLLECTIONS,
PARTICULARLY HIGH INCOME
TAXPAYERS NOT PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
IT'S DEALING WITH FAIRNESS IN
OUR SYSTEM.
SO I AM SATISFIED THIS BILL HITS
ALL THE POINTS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT AND WILL BE A MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENT BY GETTING THIS
DONE.
>> SENATOR, THERE'S NO TWO WAYS
ABOUT IT.
THIS HAS BEEN A GOOD WEEK FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN, IN ADDITION TO
THIS ECONOMIC PACKAGE, CLIMATE
PACKAGE MOVING FORWARD, THERE
WAS THE SUCCESSFUL OPERATION TO
KILL THE AL QAEDA LEADER, AL
ZAWAHIRI.
THE PASSING OF THE ACT FOR
VETERANS WITH EXPOSURE TO BURN
PITS.
GAS PRICES ARE GOING DOWN.
WE SAW THE JOBS REPORT
YESTERDAY.
BUT YOU STILL HEAR THE
CONVERSATION GOING ON AMONG
DEMOCRATS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO
TAMP SOME OF THAT DOWN?
>> THIS HAS CERTAINLY BEEN A
GOOD WEEK FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
WE ALSO PASSED FINLAND AND
SWEDEN INTO NATO.
SO WE GOT A LOT DONE THIS WEEK,
BEEN A GOOD WEEK.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS A GREAT
RECORD.
I THINK WE'RE FOCUSED ON THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS RIGHT NOW.
LET'S GET THROUGH THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS BEFORE WE START
SPECULATING ON THE NEXT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS.
>> DOES THIS HELP THE DEMOCRATS,
DO YOU THINK?
DOES THIS BRIGHTEN YOUR
PROSPECTS.
THERE HAVE BEEN CONCERNS IN YOUR
PARTY UP TO THIS POINT THAT YOU
CAN LOSE NOT JUST THE HOUSE,
BOTH THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
THIS FALL.
DOES THIS LEGISLATION TODAY, IF
IT GOES THROUGH, CHANGE THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT BUILDS ON A GREAT RECORD WE
HAVE.
CLEARLY WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WEEK WILL HELP
US IN OUR MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
FRANKLY, THE PASSAGE OF THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, WHAT THAT
MEANT KEEPING THE ECONOMY
AFLOAT.
THE CREATION OF JOBS AS YOU SAW
IN THE JOB REPORT, ALL OF THAT
ARE WAYS OF DEALING WITH OUR
ECONOMY THAT WILL HELP US IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
I MUST TELL YOU, THE CONCERN
ABOUT A WOMAN'S RIGHT,
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE THAT'S GOING
TO HELP US IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME FRONT AND CENTER
LATELY THAT WE THINK WILL HELP
US KEEPING CONTROL OF BOTH THE
HOUSE AND SENATE